[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want and
today we have Rome and Mike from the
company thank you for having us you know
III think I could be wrong but I think
this is the first time we have a guest
that's not just like in this framing
there's like a guest double guess yeah
we've had double guest before but we
always squeeze him screaming or like all
like really yeah these have like three
four people on one side yeah Jess if you
really knew just Jesus let's call just
maybe it's cuz you're wrong know if you
knew your JK news history then you would
know that when we had all guys episode
we had new people over there well you
don't know your J can use like a special
thing like a special episode like it's
um what I mean like normal JK news oh
okay sure oh yes sounds like a just
thing to say anyway
I'm not Jess and tip get my name right
so thanks for coming guys
thank you you know I think it might be
you that I read about recently in Chen's
book was it oh I guess so
terrified hahaha same rant about like
the hit like who's gonna save me what
she read yeah she actually wrote about
about Rome going on a blind date with
Ursula which I related to the most Shann
I liked your book it was awesome yeah um
could you know Priscilla
no no that's there's like six girls yeah
are participating in chance thing so
it's her know about it I was supporting
or listening desire shoutouts and so I
need that book took what's the game yeah
what's going on the game of desire no I
need a premise okay so here's the pitch
Shannon Bodrum she's a sexologist like
relationship therapist and it she took
why would he grow six girls yes I
already like this six girls that I guess
have trouble
in the dating world and so she's helping
them out and each all of them kind of
fit kind of like a different stereotype
I have different problems and she helps
people uncover being such as I'm just
this type of girl so that time let me do
it like this and then they help them
realize like oh wait I can change who I
am to meet better people your dream guy
and then also like how to how to act
like in a date and like I prepare
yourself even makeup tips and like self
defense tips like I love this she rubs
her [ __ ] and puts it all over her neck
yes yeah yeah
[Music]
pheromones yes sometimes pheromones yeah
man it was like going this way any went
this way for me cuz I was like I was
like all six girls oh yeah oh and they
got trouble what like wait what do you
think was gonna happen six girls can't
get an orgasm so she helps them through
this journey and they like they like I'm
like room you're so lucky you got to you
got to [ __ ] six girls no no I don't even
have the stamina for that else I'm too
sleepy for that but I did go on a blind
date that was cool that was my first
blind date and it was you smell her
[ __ ] immediately I mean it's somebody
here smells like [ __ ] and it's not me a
perfect question I think so were you one
of the guys that were set up with one of
the six girls yeah yeah how did it go
like well no it went and went really
well she hit me up she was like hey I
know that's kind of weird but you want
to go on a blind date honestly she was
like it's gonna be food involved Oh food
a nice conversation I can do that but on
the blind date it was cool because once
we got done with a blind date Shannon
was like hey did you notice anything
about a blind date I was like well just
I had a good time she was like why I
actually told Priscilla to disagree with
everything to disagree with that thing
you say for the first 30 for the efforts
half for the day you notice I didn't
notice because my dad you weren't like
medicine it was a testament to the
counter I can carry conversation cuz I
didn't know like I'll tell her I was
born in Germany and the first thing that
she was like no you weren't no first
thing
she was like like the journal name
wasn't the elder you harshly Brazil's
like all this shit's work yeah I mean
somebody was playing named Priscilla
she's a great girl so it was cool so did
you find anything out about yourself
it really wasn't focused on I found out
stuff about myself once I took her along
she has like a two hour assessment test
lesson here is don't listen to women and
you'll stay very stoic and chill just
like Rome understand what they're saying
just agree because you can get laid
hopefully I'm with you man saying beat
you authentic self
you sold me bro wait till you say you're
born in Germany how did you end up over
there
oh my mom my dad had sex in Germany and
when they were in the military yeah
that's what I thought kids always ask me
do I know any German I'm like I know
kindergarten and I know cuz I'm
kindergarten is the German word think
about it you kindergarten
welcome on a blind date two years house
a child and then left and then I was
there guarding then I was in Panama and
now the North Carolina would you
consider that yeah Air Force Army army
that was gonna be my next guess go down
a list of everything that like what for
that's like [ __ ] astrology people you
know Pisces know oh I could tell your
queries oh you must be rising senators
rising I knew is over there somewhere
that sounds like a Marvel movies
everything's [ __ ] rising now in
movies Jesus I'm a Libra
oh I'm born in Miami I was born in Miami
that's sexiest pop no no no no no Mike
is exotic he's being modest Mike tell
them what you are
like I said I was born in Miami and my
parents are in Jamaican so that's my
exoticness yes so casual about it that's
how I feel about Miami sit though I I
didn't experience in Miami that you see
on you try coke that's the first place
you try fat booties I wanted to shoot
clubs I tried your club I have my first
circle experience the day after prom my
best friend who's in my group camp he
went like the the night before not the
week before on his birthday and I was
like man I've been 18 for a year now I
have made you go well I grew up in a
house or my mom didn't let me do
anything
so leaving the house after 6 like once
you get in from school there's really no
excuse to go anywhere else you okay
school's out why you need to go anywhere
else it's not practice or anything so I
didn't go to shirt club until after prom
you know how to head in the night to
myself and yeah I've been hooked ever
since
the next night promised Friday went
Saturday night for young man the
experiences of the first time strip club
it's a lot especially in folks like
Miami stuff like that
I thought I was like a pretty calm
collective guy but I went to a strip
club and I immediately got nervous oh
yeah I mean you're nervous I should be I
should be going in there like yeah I'm
about to see you and I was just like oh
my god yeah I was really nervous excuse
me um can I come see your titties
[Music]
no no I we have like five of my friends
had no reason to be scared but I was
scared
first I went to the strip club there was
a girl in there her name was Miss wet
with sweat
they said mrs. cartlett sort of stage
she came to the stage she dumped her
bottle of water in her vagina they spun
around like a sprinkle and she started
wow it's a missed opportunity she's more
like a wet jet miss wet Janet's words
it's a coupie I saw some wild [ __ ] do I
saw like um there was this foam stage
and this was in TJ on other leaves were
just like they're famous for having a
[ __ ] ton of strip clubs there and stuff
and that's where I saw this stripper
like stuff dollar bills inside her couch
and I was like that's so intact area
it's disgusting screaming yes yes yes
spit it out like a money machine
well no cuz then she had like people go
in and like take it out wait with what
like their mouth oh no like in same
thing like the whole film thing right so
then they would have she would have like
this couple like motorboat her and like
they're just like filled with foam and
stuff I'm like woah this is wild like
this is what strip club
disgusting [ __ ] juice from a stripper
but dude strippers in Miami probably the
hottest on earth right no then it's it's
the top notch in there yeah that's why
it's easy to get hooked in like Miami I
kind of checked this for scientific
research yeah and I went to Miami that
my second city I lived in was Atlanta oh
no yeah so I was just like overwhelmed
my tip runneth over with strip clubs
wait is man of strip clubs is hot oh
yeah Miami's way better yeah I wouldn't
say wait Miami's better yes
Alana's right there is that right yeah
yeah I heard a man is pretty known for
their strip clothes too yeah but then so
when you come to LA it's kind of like oh
oh la is this la is watered down
everything cuz you can't get in he can't
get fully naked there's no alcohol there
is right well yes yeah I think so that's
the way if there's no alcohol
so who was that to protect the strippers
are them are the customers Oh
interesting
allegedly yeah I wasn't sure it's not I
don't think I think that's that's what
they intended I don't think it does
because at first I thought initially is
just for the women like of course
everyone gets guys get drunk and go
crazy on these naked women but then I
was an uber one day and the guy was like
noise for us so we don't spend too much
protected by this what's the purpose of
a strip club are you supposed to get all
the mental images and go jack off later
pretty much yeah yeah and it depends
like if you're rapper its promo yeah
you're rapper you get you film it oh he
went to a strip club and then they they
pretty much put it on public like he
came last night and spent ten G's and he
oh that's like a and they all talked the
thing is you going there with the
intention of like oh well at least I
went on the last time we really went was
what my birthday like two three years
ago now it's the last time and you go in
there and you're gonna in tension with
like on a budget of yeah but then you
realize you're a guy and you're stupid
in your week and you leave me like why I
spent four hundred three four hundred
dollars and you know Mike cheapness
overrides my ability to want [ __ ] no no
that's what you think Dan and when I go
in there cuz when I was 18 I was like
man if I talk to a girl she'll suck my
dick for free not thinking about like
the dates and [ __ ] and I'm in there and
I'm the whole time I'm like I'll wait
for the two-for-one lap dance deal thank
you very much and all the time I'm
judging all these girls like man you are
professional money extractors I'll wait
for that [ __ ] two-for-one lap dance
deal and in the detail be like alright
to pour lap dance and I'm like I'm gonna
go get my girl [ __ ] ya know it's a
dangerous place trying to stay away as
much as I can't only go on special
occasions so I'm feeling really good
about myself you know I've been alone
you got to go on a weekday on afternoon
and they have to pour one that specials
for $15 I say that last time you try to
go alone he ended a run into everybody
he knew yeah
there's my first time going to LA sure
close I didn't know anything about this
which one did you go home I went to
crazy girl and I wasn't crazy girls the
other one in West Hollywood oh I know
it's about him yeah yeah wild horse yeah
one of them we were just shooting at a
strip club until the day and what's fun
about it is normally I've only been at
night so you hear like cool names like
chichi to come out and show that's cool
I like we got like the [ __ ] tiger
yeah of course through the day it's like
come to the stage right now the elevator
in your life they were gearing up
everybody a new tired
Jumbotron lady thought it was a low-key
night it was they were literally I left
the house at like 12:30 at night I was
sleeping before I left - I was like I'm
gonna go to strip club it's late no
one's there everyone's sleeping gonna
have me a dream road was empty I was
like let me go have a drink see some you
know maybe get a dancer to come back
home and let nothing happen I got that I
got there and it was literally like all
of the way there people with cameras I
got like five pictures taken of me
haha you didn't want to leave like right
away like I know where we live have you
Drive and I and I have to pay for it all
to get in you take Rome to the strip
club burrs birthday two years ago okay
right I did yeah well we are you were
there
how many lap dances did you get in
prison birthday how many lap dance do
you think collectively that you got hmm
Blue is for three of us I think they all
pay for me at least one that bit so you
need me before not dance yeah oh yeah
way more than that but yeah I met at
bachelor party okay my friend gets 14
lap dances he pays for them or people to
know we're all getting him for so many
[ __ ] lap down over there but I
becoming his pence well recently like I
mean right we're basically at the point
where I'm like I'm like I feel
uncomfortable like I'm like should I
call my wife and tell her I love her
like
so much happening and then with this guy
I'm like dude I gotta watch this guy get
married and I got to know that he had 14
[ __ ] laugh misses
I don't we could never tell her what's
the what's the breaking point Matt for
his birthday no that was the ones we got
him yeah but he had way more but but the
thing is I we what we do is we scoped
out which girls and then we stick to the
ones that are good so out of like 20 of
the girls like five of them are doing
they work hard they work hard you want I
don't care if you even look that good
long as you work hard in there that's
what I want to see I come from a
background of working hard at creating
we all create you want a great
entertainer that's what I'm saying that
I don't want it like this is you love me
someone's passionate about their work
exactly exactly and I know you don't but
when I leave I want to be like wow she
really you want to like pretend in your
head that maybe there was a different
like magic moment that we had for five
hundred dollars yeah I think she loved
me yes just a superficial I end up being
really picky to like it took you forever
to find us necklaces or everyone on my
tips we're taking like an hour just to
pick a girl just get the biggest tease
cuz we were in Vegas at sapphire
something blue set like the biggest
[ __ ] stripper
it was huge it's not a big ice makes
around they make right it's so big it
has a car dealership in it like three
stories listen Joe I gotta pick the
right fondos know that Bri god I was
like damn good so I got another stripper
for one of our friends and she just
pulled her [ __ ] jet I mean her shirt
off and she put her [ __ ] nipples on
top of her nipples did this [ __ ] I was
like what the [ __ ]
no I don't know what to see I don't know
about like looking at this because I'm
looking at my friend's titties
weightlessly wish you pulled out your
friends you pulled out your friend she
took off her shirt and then she took off
her shirt and he [ __ ] that's greater
take yeah nipple nipple slap there I
completely miss that but I that's what
I've been talking about
yeah you were there yeah I know I can
probably didn't want to look probably
though my friend cans that'sthat's his
girl I wouldn't look okay come on it was
fast you're watching you know she just
pulls it down and I'm like oh if you
ever get a chance there's a place in
Atlanta I don't know if it still called
Clermont lounge but it's like the oldest
it's like it's a landmark in Atlanta is
called Clermont lounge is where of the
60 and up strippers are so are you going
there and 60 years old yeah 52 see it's
like a landfill to be like just what you
go there's the old colonial strip like
you know for the old mill man like the
Quaker pattern hats and so you go in my
homeboys head he win there and never the
old lady to came out and she he's saying
her down to the like pigskin and she
when I throw the ball around
[Laughter]
so there's special places nice to he'll
give my grandma's but yeah like they
don't look very good like that there's
guilt porn dude there's good like you I
know you never heard before but I'm not
opposed a little guilt I'm not opposed
to look Wow
a little guilt like nine hours
because I like the opposite you like
young girls you like girls who are
grandmas no no like I've seen like yeah
like young girls with old dudes right
but then like but then I can't see old
ladies with young dudes why I don't know
it looks stressful I'm not even talking
about MILF though I'm talking about
guilt I know I know I know I know
you you've never you tell me you've
clicked on gil-find suicide when their
faces matte oh but they body still a
little ooh yeah that really gets me I'm
like well that makes sense no no that
makes sense that my face is older than
their bodies I'm talking about
DILF like she looks like she's a [ __ ]
lunch lady GILF you know like oh like
she's out of shape guilt yeah she's a
good girl like she's a great guilt okay
that's what I'm saying but there is a
there's a side of me that likes normalcy
Oh like say you know can never mind
sometimes I think a porn is like - it's
too polished right okay you like a
little girls they're all nines and
change I want to see you three see some
razor bumps no no it feels real and
authentic and there's passion there's a
little more passion it's like a
boyfriend and girlfriend recording on
their [ __ ] webcam and I'm watching
that [ __ ] you don't feel like there's
eight dudes in the room behind a camera
with a sound you just you know if I can
imagine them saying all right we need we
need the gaffer to come in we need our
name and imagine him saying
points points all for playing over plan
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you